LAURENCE MORONEY: At Google, we
have lots of developer events.
And today, I'm talking
with Megan Krilanovich,
along with her special guest,
who makes many of them happen.
So Firebase always has
great representation
at events like Google I/O. We
have our own summits and lots
of other things.
And Megan, you're the one
that drives all of this.
You're the brains behind it all.
What's it like?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
It's pretty great.
So I think I have
one of the best jobs
ever, which is that I help
our engineers and our product
managers get out to events
and talk to developers
throughout the year.
So we go to about 100,
150 events every year--
LAURENCE MORONEY: That many?
Wow.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: --and
send hundreds of Firebasers
to these events
every year, as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
And one of the things
that Firebase always
seems to be synonymous with
at events is great swag.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: That is true.
We do have some
pretty great swag.
There's a Firebase hot sauce,
which is one of my favorites.
And now we've started
doing annual additions.
So we're hoping that they kind
of become collector's items--
or, at least, I've
started to collect them.
One of my other favorites
was the Firebase sweatband.
So, you know, it's a lot
of work being a developer.
When you start coding, you know,
you get hot, you get sweaty,
and you need your
sweatband to keep cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So we've
seen that great video of David.
He's covering himself
from head to toe--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --in
these sweatbands, right?
So it's like-- so, would you
recommend developers do that?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Absolutely.
You know, whatever you
need to do to code hard.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So I was
speaking at an event in the UK
earlier this year.
And you remember we sent, like,
a whole bunch of hot sauce
there?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Mm-hmm.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it didn't
quite go according to plan.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Oh, man.
I think that the truck that it
was being shipped on actually
went off the side of the road.
I think everyone was OK.
But the hot sauce was not, so
it never made it to that event.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And so, you ended up
shipping a whole bunch
of hot sauce to me.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: That's true!
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I packed
my suitcase full of hot sauce
to go to the UK--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Yep.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Let's just
say Security gave me, like,
a very interesting expression
when they were scanning my bag,
so--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: But this
is the true Firebase spirit.
Anything for our developers.
You know, we always want
to go the extra mile.
And if that means packing
hundreds of bottles
of hot sauce in your
suitcase, then that's
what we've got to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I have to say,
I kept some of the
hot sauce at home--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Oh, good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --and my wife
makes amazing chicken wings
with it.
So we have to try it some time.
And one of these
days, I'm going to do,
like, a Firecast on how to make
chicken wings with Firebase
hot sauce.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: I-- yes.
I would love to be a
guest on that show.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We'll
bring them and put them
in the middle of the table.
So, one of the things
also, with Megan--
I don't know if you can see
on camera, but Megan, like--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Oh, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
--brings Didi--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Here, Didi.
[KISSING NOISES] Come on.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --with her.
And, like, Didi is almost,
like, Google-- like,
our Firebase mascot dog.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: She
is the Firebase dog.
You know, Google is
very dog-friendly.
And I worked with Firebase
before the Google acquisition.
And when we came to Google,
I kept telling everyone
that they should get a dog.
And then I realized, maybe
I should just get the dog.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
And then Didi came
along and loved you.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: She did.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You know, even,
like, her ear, she
has one up, one down.
It reminds me of
the Firebase logo.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: That's true!
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Did she inspire it?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: You know,
I would like to say yes.
But I don't think
that's the case.
We'll just say she
embodies Firebase.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, sounds good.
So she's just a--
just a darling little dog.
So she definitely
embodies Firebase.
Now, you mentioned
you came as part
of the Firebase acquisition.
So what was it like going
from, like, start up to then
being part of Google?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: It was a
pretty great journey, you know.
I joined one year
before acquisition,
so I was there a year.
And from then, we grew from
seven employees to over 20.
And then we were
acquired by Google.
So I always say that tech years
are kind of like dog years.
So it's about a 7:1 ratio.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: So
time moves very quickly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So a lot
has changed since you were--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
A lot has changed.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --became
part of Google, you know.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: That's right.
We used to bake
cookies in our own--
in our own kitchen,
back in the old days.
And, you know, things like
that don't happen anymore.
But we still have a
lot of fun as a team.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now we can
just go to a micro kitchen
and take some cookies, right?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
That's correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So to--
back to events for a second.
So, like, one of the things
that, all these events,
from small to large, like,
all the way up from, like,
G2G Meetups, to Google I/O, and
that kind of stuff, it's like--
it's a big logistic issue
getting the right speakers
to go to the right events so
that we can support and love
our community.
And it's like, how is it
that you managed all of this?
It sounds so difficult.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: know,
it takes a lot of time,
and a lot of it is just
about taking care of each
and every one of our speakers,
and the awesome Googlers that
go to these events,
so that, they
can keep going to as
many events as possible
throughout the year.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Do
you have a favorite?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
A favorite event?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Oh, man.
You know, there's some
that we've been going
to forever, like, some of the--
some college hackathons that
we go to, year after year.
And so I really like some
of these ones that are just
Firebase tradition to go to.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And it's great, like,
to work with students, like--
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: It is.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --to
see them getting started,
and beginning their
journey, right?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
It's really cool.
And some of the things that they
build in, you know, 24-48 hours
is absolutely amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So beyond, like,
the hackathons and college
hackathons, obviously we
have the big events like Google
I/O, and that kind of stuff.
Any good ones coming up
that you're working on?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
Well, we are going
to have an event on
October 31 in Amsterdam,
in the Netherlands.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Halloween in Amsterdam!
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: We're
super excited about this.
We'll be sending a huge
portion of the Firebase team,
lots of really great sessions,
and instructor-led trainings,
and office hours.
And so, developers
will get to have
just a whole day with
the Firebase team,
and ask any questions
that they've
been storing up over the year.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We did a
great one last year in Berlin.
And it was, like, there
were-- so many people went.
And it was a fabulous
event, right?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So,
hoping for the same again.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Absolutely.
It's going to be great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So if I'm a developer and
I want to get started,
what's the best
place to get going?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
I recommend that you
go to firebase.google.com and
get started on our code labs.
We have great code labs
for iOS, Android, and web.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: Or, you know,
come meet the Firebase team
at one of these events.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds good.
MEGAN KRILANOVICH: We would
love to see you there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So can
I go to the Amsterdam one?
MEGAN KRILANOVICH:
Yes, Laurence.
If I'm going, you're
going, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Sounds good to me.
So thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee With a Googler."
And thanks, Megan, and thanks,
Didi, for being our guests.
And as you heard,
there's so many events.
They're always going on.
We have, from Google
Developer groups,
all the way up to
things like Google I/O,
and this event that's coming
in Amsterdam on Halloween,
October 31st.
So check in on
firebase.google.com,
and check out the links
below to learn more
about some of the
events, and Megan,
the person who's
making them all happen.
So, thanks again, Megan.